>> PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
THE GIRLS MOVED INTO
THEIR STYLISH NEW DIGS...
>> TOP MODEL, BABY! TOP MODEL!
>> AND MONIQUE
WENT ON THE OFFENSIVE.
>> THINK THEY'RE GONNA WANNA
SLEEP HERE NOW?
>> MONIQUE--SHE STOLE MY BED.
I WANTED TO FIGHT HER.
>> AT THE PHOTO SHOOT,
MICHELLE ROCKED
HER CONTROVERSIAL PHOTO,
AND MELROSE WAS A DIVA
ON THE SET.
>> I'VE BEEN READY FOR,
LIKE, SIX HOURS,
BUT THEN I GOT MY MASSAGE
WITH MY MAKEUP ON, AND THEN...
>> REALLY?
THE ATTITUDE RIGHT NOW--
JUST LISTEN.
>> AND CHRISTIAN'S
LACK OF ORIGINALITY
JUST COULDN'T MAKE THE CUT,
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
12 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> I SUCK SO BAD AT RUNWAY.
>> NO, BUT YOU STILL LOOKED GOOD
WHEN YOU WERE--WHEN YOU DID IT.
>> THANK YOU.
I LOVE MEGAN.
LIKE, SHE'S JUST SUCH A GREAT,
LIKE, PERSONALITY.
I'VE GOTTEN REALLY CLOSE TO HER.
>> WE'RE PRACTICING OUR, UM,
RUNWAY WALK TOGETHER.
WE'RE COMPETING
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
YOU KNOW,
BUT THAT'S THE WAY IT SHOULD BE.
IT'S SHOULD BE, LIKE,
HELP EACH OTHER, YOU KNOW?
GET EACH OTHER TO THE TOP.
>> I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE.
AND I'VE BEEN THINKING A LOT
ABOUT CHRISTIAN TODAY,
JUST HOW MUCH
SHE MUST BE GOING THROUGH,
AND THAT I COULD BE THERE.
>> IF WE CATCH YOU BEING A DIVA
IN YOUR NEXT PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU'RE GOING HOME.
>> OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD.
I'M HAPPY THAT
THEY SAW POTENTIAL IN ME,
AND I'M GONNA WORK MY ASS OFF.
>> MELROSE.
>> THAT WAS SUCH AN ACT.
"I'M SORRY!"
DID YOU SEE HER
SQUEEZING OUT TEARS?
>> MM-HMM.
>> SHE'S SO FAKE.
THAT'S THE PERSON I CAN'T STAND
THE MOST IN THIS HOUSE.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> READ IT!
>> "EVERY MORNING,
I HAVE TO HAVE TWO GLASSES
OF FRESH-SQUEEZED O JAYS
TO GET ME GOING.
THIS MORNING,
I SUGGEST YOU DO THE SAME."
>> "O JAYS."
>> THE JAYS!
(alarm clocks beeping)
>> I'M PRETTY PISSED OFF
BECAUSE THIS ALARM CLOCK--
IT'S LIKE FOUR OR FIVE OF 'EM
THAT'S GONE OFF,
AND I'M STILL TRYING TO SLEEP,
OKAY? I'M SHUSH-ING
TO GET MY BEAUTY SLEEP, OKAY?
SO I END UP WAKING UP ON A VERY,
VERY BAD SIDE THIS MORNING.
>> MONIQUE JUST HAS
THIS ATTITUDE.
SHE JUST LOOKS AT YOU--
SHE'S LIKE--
LIKE "YOU'RE DESPICABLE.
GET AWAY FROM ME."
CAN'T STAND THE BITCHINESS.
♪♪
>> ALL RIGHT, GIRLS.
>> HI!
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> HEY.
>> WE CAME TO EAT BREAKFAST
AND BREAK SOME BREAD
AND CHITCHAT.
>> YOU ALL WANT MAKEOVERS?
>> YEAH!
>> YOU ALWAYS--
EVERYBODY ALWAYS TALKS
ABOUT MAKEOVERS--THEY LIKE IT.
AND WHEN THEY GET THEM,
YOU ALL BUST OUT CRYING.
>> MY HAIR GROWS SO FAST,
I DON'T CARE. SHAVE IT.
>> I DO. I'VE GOT GOOD HAIR.
>> IT GROWS FAST.
>> PLEASE.
>> SO I WANT
TO TALK TO YOU GIRLS ABOUT
DRAWING ON YOUR EXPERIENCES
TO MOTIVATE YOUR MODELING.
FOR EXAMPLE, MEGAN--
WHEN YOU WERE SPEAKING
DURING CASTING,
THE FIRST THING I SAID WAS,
I LOVE YOUR STRENGTH
OF CHARACTER.
>> WHEN I WAS 9,
I WAS IN A PLANE CRASH.
MY MOTHER EVENTUALLY DIED
IN THE AIRPLANE.
I FEEL LIKE
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN AN OPTIMIST.
IT'S JUST WHO I AM.
I WILL SURVIVE.
LIKE, I'M TOTALLY GONNA,
YOU KNOW?
IT'S JUST LIKE--
YOU WON'T LET YOURSELF GO.
>> LET ME TELL YOU,
IF YOU GUYS WANT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL MODELS,
GOING TO A PLACE
OF VULNERABILITY
IS ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT THINGS TO DO.
BUT IF YOU CAN DO IT,
IT WILL REALLY COME THROUGH
IN YOUR PHOTOS.
IT WAS GREAT HAVING BREAKFAST.
>> YEAH! BYE!
>> WE'LL SEE YOU SOON. BYE.
(knock on door)
>> WHO'S GONNA OPEN THE DOOR?
>> HELLO!
>> (screaming)
♪♪
>> HEY. HOW ARE YOU?
COME ON IN.
FOLLOW ME, MAN.
WORK IT.
>> WORK IT!
>> WHOO!
>> (screaming)
>> IN THE LIVING ROOM,
WE HAVE A FULL-FLEDGED SALON,
WITH STATIONS AND MIRRORS
AND EVERYTHING.
>> THIS USED TO BE
YOUR LIVING ROOM.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT NOW IT HAS TURNED
INTO THE FRéDéRIC FEKKAI SALON.
>> WHOO!
>> FRéDéRIC FEKKAI IS A LEGEND
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
I MEAN, HE HAS DONE MY HAIR
SINCE I WAS 17 YEARS OLD,
WORKING A RUNWAY IN PARIS.
SO EVERYONE TODAY
IS GOING TO LEAVE
LOOKING LIKE A TOP MODEL.
LIKE THEY ARE...
>> HEY! OH, YEAH!
>> ARE YOU READY TO HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA GET?
>> YEAH!
>> FIRST UP--MISS MELROSE.
>> WHOA.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I SEE THESE BRIGHT, BIG,
ALIENESQUE BLUE EYES,
AND THEN THERE'S THIS HAIR
THAT'S KIND OF...
(imitating buzzer)
>> (imitating buzzer)
>> SO WE ARE TAKING YOU
TO THE NEXT LEVEL, BABY.
>> (screaming)
>> PLATINUM BLOND,
à LA NADJA AUERMANN,
WHO WAS A TOP MODEL IN MY DAY.
MISS BROOKE--
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU SHOULD BE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT OF
THE "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
ASSOCIATION.
SO YOU NEED TO BE EDGED OUT.
>> OH, NO!
>> VOILà, BROOKE!
YOU ARE GETTING CHOCOLATE-BROWN.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> MISS EUGENA--
YOU THINK YOU'RE BETTER
THAN EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> YOU DON'T LIKE
THE LAST SEASON
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
GIRLS.
>> THEY'RE BORING.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
THEY'RE REALLY GENERIC.
>> AND A GIRL THAT THINKS
SHE'S BETTER THAN EVERYBODY ELSE
NEEDS SOME HAIR, GIRL.
>> WHOA!
>> MISS MEGAN,
THE PIXIE NEEDS TO BE TAKEN
TO THE NEXT LEVEL, BABY.
>> OOH!
>> SO YOU ARE GOING TO BE
A PIXIE BLONDE--OOH!
(bell dings)
>> ANCHAL--VOíLA!
YOU'RE GETTING LAYERS
AND SOME SHORTENING.
>> I NEED LAYERS.
I'VE HAD THIS
FOR YEARS AND YEARS.
IT'S TIME TO GET RID OF IT.
>> YOUR FOREHEAD RIGHT NOW
IS REALLY, REALLY LOW.
SO WE ACTUALLY HAVE
THREADERS BACK THERE,
AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK
YOUR HAIRLINE JUST A LITTLE BIT.
>> SO YOU'RE GONNA GO
FROM AN ANCHAL FOREHEAD
TO A TYRA BANKS FIVE-HEAD, GIRL.
ALL RIGHT, MONIQUE.
WHAT DO WE DO TO THIS GIRL
THAT ALREADY LOOKS GREAT?
THERE'S A PICTURE OF ME
A LONG TIME AGO.
I WAS LAYING ON THE SAND
IN JAMAICA.
AND WE USED THAT PICTURE
AS INSPIRATION
FOR MONIQUE'S HAIR.
>> OH, MY LORD, YOU KNOW.
I KINDA WANTED IT
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
LIKE, I MEAN, CUT MY HAIR
OR SOMETHING OR, LIKE,
DYE IT A DIFFERENT COLOR.
>> MISS CARIDEE,
WHEN YOUR HAIR IS LIKE THIS,
YOU TEND TO LOOK
A LITTLE TOO ACTRESS-Y.
SO CAN YOU LET YOUR HAIR DOWN
FOR FRéDéRICK?
HE'S GONNA HELP.
>> LET THE MASTER TAKE CONTROL.
>> OH, YOU WANT WEAVE.
OH, HELLO.
>> OH, YAY!
>> A.J., WE HAD TO CHANNEL
LINDA EVANGELISTA,
CIRCA 1992, BABY.
WE'RE GONNA LIGHTEN IT UP A BIT.
MEGG.
SOMETIMES IT'S ABOUT
EMBRACING WHAT GOD GAVE YOU.
SO WE KNOW YOU HAVE
A LITTLE FRIZZY CURL.
AND YOU'RE GONNA GET
MORE OF IT TODAY.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> SO, MICHELLE,
YOU'RE A LITTLE MOUSY.
SO WE HAVE TO THROW AWAY
THE MOUSE,
AND BRING THE FIRE, BABY.
>> (all squeal)
>> AMANDA, WE'RE TAKING YOU
FIRE ENGINE.
>> BUT YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TEXTURE, MICHELLE,
AND AMANDA, YOU'RE GONNA
BE STRAIGHT AND CLASSY,
LIKE YOU ARE.
AND LAST, BUT NOT LEAST,
MISS JAEDA.
ONE THING THAT YOU SAID IS,
"I'M THE PRETTIEST GIRL
IN SCHOOL, YOU KNOW.
EVERYBODY SAYS HOW PRETTY I AM."
BUT ACTUALLY,
IN THIS COMPETITION,
YOU'RE ACTUALLY
THE MOST HANDSOME.
NOW THAT MIGHT SOUND
LIKE AN INSULT,
BUT WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS,
IT'S KIND OF A BOYISH QUALITY
TO YOUR FACE,
AND THAT PHOTOGRAPHS
REALLY STRONG.
SO TO EMBRACE THAT,
I CHANNELED AN ACTRESS.
HALLE BERRY HAIR.
>> (all screaming)
>> YOU CALLED IT THIS MORNING.
YOU SAID, "YOU COULD
CUT MY HAIR OFF. I DON'T CARE."
>> YOUR MODELING
WILL HAVE TO CHANGE WITH THIS.
YOU HAVE TO GO TOTALLY AGAINST
WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN RAISED TO BE.
OKAY, AND ALL OF YOU
ARE GONNA GET THESE
ABSOLUTELY GLORIOUS LOOKS.
AND YOU'RE GONNA BE MODELING
IN A SEXY PHOTO SHOOT
IN METALLIC SWIMSUITS.
ARE WE READY?
>> YEAH.
>> GIMME SOME LOVE! LET'S GO!
>> (screaming)
>> SEE YOU ALL LATER. OKAY.
'BYE.
>> 'BYE. THANK YOU.
>> COME HERE.
I'D BE HARD.
>> YOU KNOW
IT'S GONNA LOOK GOOD.
>> I'M SCARED. I'M, LIKE,
SCARED I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO PULL IT OFF. OH, MY GOD.
>> JAEDA.
>> I KNEW THEY WERE
SAVING ME FOR LAST FOR A REASON.
>> I DON'T WANNA LOOK THE SAME.
CHOP MY HAIR OFF!
♪♪
>> I THINK IT ROCKS, YOU KNOW.
I THINK IT LOOKS GOOD.
IT'S MY NEW
SIGNATURE HAIR, LADIES.
I CAN DO MORE HEADBANGING
IN THIS HAIR
THAN I COULD THE OTHER WAY.
>> IT DOESN'T HURT,
DOES IT, ANCHAL?
SHE'S LIKE, "NO. (grunts)"
>> AAH. OKAY, YEAH,
THAT ONE HURT.
THE THREADING PART,
IT HURT LIKE A BITCH.
BUT INSTEAD OF BEING TWO HEADS,
I'M, LIKE, THREE, FOUR HEADS.
I FEEL GREAT.
>> IT'S NOT GONNA
LOOK GOOD BLONDE.
>> WHY?
>> 'CAUSE I JUST FEEL
LIKE MY HAIR POPS OUT
WITH DARK FEATURES.
>> WE TRY AND FIGURE IT OUT,
AND I THINK YOU'LL LOOK YOUNGER.
I THINK YOU'LL LOOK
A LITTLE FRESHER.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE
MELROSE IS ALL UPSET
ABOUT BEING BLONDE.
>> HONESTLY, IF I WAS
IN HER POSITION,
I WOULDN'T WANT
TO BE BLONDE EITHER.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO MEG RYAN?
MEG RYAN'S GONE HOME.
THAT LOOKS SO GOOD.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT'S SEXY.
>> I'VE NEVER HAD BROWN HAIR.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A BLONDIE,
BUT FRéDéRICK FEKKAI
IS THE MASTER,
AND IT TURNED OUT BEAUTIFUL.
>> HONESTLY, I DON'T KNOW
IF I CAN WORK
WITH THIS NEW HAIR.
I'M JUST REALLY BAD
WITH HAIR IN GENERAL.
PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING GIRLY,
I'M BAD AT.
>> ME AND MY SISTER
WERE KINDA DISAPPOINTED
ABOUT HAVING DIFFERENT LOOKS,
BECAUSE NOW WE CAN'T SWITCH.
WE CAN'T, LIKE,
TRICK PEOPLE AS EASILY.
>> OH, GOD.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA TRY--
NO. DO NOT.
>> WAIT A MINUTE--BUT SHE'S
CUTTING THIS PART BACK HERE.
>> I'M SO UPTIGHT.
(screams)
>> THIS IS FUN.
>> OOH! (sobs)
OH, MY GOD! (screams)
>> OKAY, THAT'S GOOD.
>> OH, THAT IS--
(crying)
>> ALL RIGHT,
IT ALREADY LOOKS GOOD.
>> WELL, SHE CALMED DOWN.
>> WHATEVER.
>> I JUST FEEL SO MASCULINE.
I FEEL LIKE I'VE LOST MY, LIKE,
GIRLISH THING GOING ON.
♪♪
>> I LOOKED IN THE MIRROR
AFTER THEY GOT DONE
STYLING IT AND EVERYTHING.
I JUST FELT SO BEAUTIFUL
ON THE OUTSIDE,
AND I FEEL BEAUTIFUL
ON THE INSIDE,
JUST KIND OF ALL,
LIKE, MATCHED UP.
>> I THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE
GONNA CHOP IT OFF
AND SHAVE ME DOWN
AND ALL THAT STUFF,
BUT I WAS PLEASED
WITH MY MAKEOVER.
>> WOW,
THERE'S SO MANY GOOD SHOTS,
I DON'T WANNA MISS 'EM.
>> OH, MY GOD.
YOUR EYES
ARE SO POPPING OUT NOW.
>> IT WAS AMAZING HAVING
FRéDéRICK FEKKAI WORK ON US.
HE CUT MY HAIR
IN, LIKE, TWO MINUTES.
AND I'M, LIKE,WOW
IT LOOKS PERFECT.
>> NICE.
>> MELROSE REALLY IS
JUST A CONTROL FREAK.
A LOT OF YOUNG GIRLS THAT TRY
TO OVERCONTROL THE SITUATION,
THEY DON'T GO TOO FAR.
>> HER EYEBROWS--SHE LOOK CRAZY.
YOU LOOK SO--
>> THIS IS MY LOOK.
>> THAT LOOKS CRAZY.
♪♪
>> WE HAVE TO MAKE IT DARKER.
>> NO, I HATE THIS COLOR. PLEASE
WHEN I FIRST GOT MY HAIR STYLED,
I WAS IN SHOCK.
IT'S STILL A LITTLE BIT
TOO LIGHT FOR MY LIKING,
AND I'M NOT A SMOOTH GIRL.
I LIKE SPIKES.
♪♪
>> J, LOOK AT MISS MONIQUE.
>> LOOK AT--LOOK AT HER FACE.
LOOKS LIKE IT JUST STINKS.
>> OH, GOD, WHY, WHY?
>> SHE REPRESENTS CRYING.
IF SHE WANTS TO CRY,
THEN LET HER CRY.
>> WHAT?
>> PLEASE. LOOK AT THAT PICTURE
OF TYRA ON THE WALL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THERE'S TYRA
WITHOUT HER WEAVE ON.
>> (crying)
>> GRR. I'M NOT IN THE MOOD
FOR THESE GIRLS.
>> (sobbing)
>> COME HERE, GIRL.
>> WHAT'S THE STORY?
>> I'M JUST HAVING A BAD DAY.
I CAN'T EVEN SPEAK,
'CAUSE IT'S LIKE
NO ONE'S GOING TO HELP ME.
AND SO I CAN'T SLEEP.
>> DO YOU WANT THIS CAREER?
THIS IS NOT HARD.
YOU ARE GETTING
A FRESH HAIR WEAVE
BY A MASTER STYLIST,
AND IF THERE ARE ALARMS
GOING OFF, PUT IN EAR PLUGS.
TO SEE THESE YOUNG GIRLS,
WHO SUPPOSEDLY WANTED
TO BE HERE SO BADLY,
JUST KIND OF THROW IT OFF
AND SAY, "OH, I DON'T LIKE IT,"
IT JUST DISGUSTS ME,
AND IT MAKES ME
NOT WANT TO BE HERE.
GUYS, WHEN YOU WALK
INTO THIS BUSINESS,
YOU WALK INTO THIS BUSINESS
AS BLANK CANVASES.
I WISH THAT,
WHEN I WAS 18 OR 19,
I HAD PEOPLE COME IN
AND TAKE ME TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
SO YOU HATE YOUR HAIR,
AND--AND YOU'RE
ACTUALLY BEING INSULTING
IN FRONT OF A MASTER
WHO'S BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS--
NO, YOU WERE.
JUST LISTEN FOR ONE SECOND.
MISS THING'S CRYING UP THERE
'CAUSE SHE GOT HER TRACKS OUT.
AND THIS AND THAT,
AND IT'S LIKE... UGH.
YOU'RE INSULTING OUR GUESTS.
YOU'RE INSULTING TYRA,
INEVITABLY.
I'M, LIKE, OVER IT.
I'M JUST GONNA GO HOME TO SLEEP.
♪♪
>> I LOOK LIKE A STRANGER.
>> I've always wanted you
to have, like,
white-blond hair.
>> OH, IT'S WHITE. IT'S WHITE.
>> I'm so proud of you.
You have no idea.
>> YEAH, BUT EVERYONE WAS--
SO MANY GIRLS WERE, LIKE,
CRYING AND FREAKING OUT.
>> Oh, really?
They didn't like it?
>> WE GOT--OR THEY GOT--
BAWLED OUT.
♪♪
>> DUDE, I LOVE MY HAIR.
IT LOOKS SO HOT
WITH EVERY OUTFIT.
(hums)
(screams)
>> IT'S TYRA MAIL!
>> "TRUE QUEENS
ARE NATURAL BEAUTIES
THAT DON'T NEED MAKEUP
TO MAKE IT TO THE TOP...
SO DON'T WEAR ANY TODAY.
GOT IT?"
>> (cheering)
♪♪
>> GOOD MORNING.
IT WAS A REALLY LONG DAY
YESTERDAY.
THERE WERE A LOT OF TEARS.
TODAY YOU GET AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE THAT UP TO ME.
I WANT YOU GIRLS
TO TRY AND IMPRESS ME
WITH YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF MAKEUP.
I'VE GOT
THE WHOLE COVERGIRL COLLECTION
HERE WITH ME TODAY
AND THE NEW QUEEN COLLECTION,
WHICH WAS DEVELOPED
FOR WOMEN OF COLOR
BY QUEEN LATIFAH.
COVERGIRL IS ALL-INCLUSIVE,
AND THERE IS SOMETHING
FOR EVERYBODY BEHIND ME.
SO YOUR CHALLENGE TODAY IS,
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU GIRLS
30 SECONDS TO GRAB THE MAKEUP
THAT BEST SUITS YOU BEHIND ME,
AND THEN YOU'RE GONNA MEET ME
IN THE ELEVATOR.
AND ALONG THE WAY,
WE'RE GONNA STOP
ON DIFFERENT FLOORS.
ONE FLOOR,
YOU'RE GONNA FIND WARDROBE.
ON ANOTHER FLOOR,
YOU'RE GONNA FIND
SHOES AND ACCESSORIES.
DURING THAT TIME,
YOU'RE GONNA PUT TOGETHER
YOUR OWN NEW YOUNG QUEEN LOOK.
WHEN WE GET TO THE TOP FLOOR,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
WITH A COVERGIRL EXECUTIVE,
AND YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO SELL THEM ON YOUR LOOK.
IF YOU MISS THE ELEVATOR DOORS,
YOU'RE INSTANTLY DISQUALIFIED.
>> GO!
>> NINE SECONDS, GIRLS.
(buzzer sounds)
>> OH!
>> WE'RE GOING UP.
>> YOU GUYS GET CLOTHES.
YOU HAVE 30 SECONDS, ALL RIGHT?
30 SECONDS. GRAB SOME CLOTHES.
GRAB SOME CLOTHES.
(bell dings)
>> OKAY, WE'VE GOT SHOES
AND ACCESSORIES OVER HERE.
TEN SECONDS.
NO, THEY'VE GOTTA BE ON YOU,
NOT CARRYING THEM.
(speaks indistinctly)
(buzzer sounds)
>> FREAK. STUPID.
>> WHEN MONIQUE
DOESN'T MAKE THE ELEVATOR,
EVERYONE IS LIKE,
"OH, WE'RE ALL GETTING
BEATEN UP TONIGHT IN THE HOUSE,
FOR SURE."
>> GET OFF THE ELEVATOR.
(bell dings)
>> YOU GIRLS ARE GOING
TO ROOM 3108,
WHERE YOU'RE GONNA MEET
WITH YOUR COVERGIRL EXECUTIVE.
>> (cheering)
>> WHAT'S UP, GIRLS?
I AM HERE
REPRESENTING COVERGIRL
AND THE QUEEN COLLECTION.
>> WHOO!
>> YOU HAD TO DO
YOUR OWN MAKEUP TODAY.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU GET
TO BALLER STATUS LIKE ME,
YOU GET TO HIRE
A MAKEUP ARTIST.
SO THE WONDERFUL ROXANNA FLOYD,
WHO IS MY MAKEUP ARTIST,
IS HERE.
>> HI.
>> HEY.
>> DON'T THEY LOOK GREAT?
>> THEY'RE BEAUTIFUL.
>> THEY ARE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO
IS TALK TO EACH ONE OF YOU
ABOUT WHAT A YOUNG QUEEN LOOK
IS TO YOU.
DO WHAT'D YOU GO FOR?
>> A QUEEN SHOULD BE BEAUTIFUL
WITHOUT MAKEUP AND WITH.
I THINK IT WAS BRONZE,
BUT IN THE SCURRY I'M NOT SURE
WHAT EXACTLY I PUT ON.
>> DOESN'T MATTER.
YOU COME IN HERE
AND JUST ACT LIKE,
HEY, THIS IS WHAT I AM,
THIS IS WHAT IT IS.
AND I THINK THAT CONFIDENCE
WILL GO A LONG WAY FOR YOU.
>> I TRIED TO JUST HIGHLIGHT
MY EYES WITH JUST MASCARA.
>> GREAT VIBE, BAD SHOES.
THAT'S IT.
>> DAMN IT!
>> DAMN THOSE SHOES.
>> TODAY I WAS GOING
FOR THE QUEEN OF BEACH.
>> TYRA B. SAID
WE GON' TAKE 'EM
TO THE BEACH, ROXIE.
SILLY LIKE WE AT THE BEACH
IN THE '60s, THOUGH.
>> I THOUGHT
THAT A COVERGIRL QUEEN
SHOULD BE FRESH,
CONFIDENT AND REGAL.
>> I THINK YOU NAILED IT
WITH THE WARDROBE.
WE JUST WISH YOU WOULDA USED
A LITTLE MORE OF THE PRODUCTS.
>> WHAT I DID
WAS KIND OF A COLOR SPLASH,
BECAUSE BEING A WOMAN OF COLOR,
WE HAVE A PROBLEM
WEARING COLORFUL EYESHADOW,
SO I JUST WANTED
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE FACT
THAT YOU GUYS
PROVIDED COLORS FOR US.
>> AND I THOUGHT YOU LOOK GREAT.
>> I'M STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL,
SO THE FIRST THING I THOUGHT
WHEN I THOUGHT QUEEN
WAS PROM QUEEN.
>> THE PROM QUEEN.
WE WANTED TO KNOW
WHAT A YOUNG QUEEN WAS TO YOU,
AND WE THOUGHT
YOU DID A GREAT JOB
HAVING AN IDEA OF WHAT THAT WAS.
>> I WENT FOR
THE MORE NATURAL LOOK.
I USED
THE SOFT SABLE LOOSE COLOR
TO SHINE UP MY FACE.
>> YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL.
YOU'RE GORGEOUS.
>> STUNNING. STUNNING.
>> LET YOUR PERSONALITY OUT
FOR US TO SHARE WITH YOU.
>> I WAS GOING FOR
THE TYPE OF STYLE
WHERE YOU COULD GO OUT,
YOU KNOW, GO TO THE MOVIES.
ESPECIALLY WITH
MY CRAZY, WILD HAIR.
>> YOU HAVE GORGEOUS LIPS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> WHICH WE WOULD HAVE LOVED
TO SEE WITH MORE OF OUR...
>> COLOR.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I JUST USED
COVERGIRL TRUE BLEND
TO HIDE ALL THOSE BLEMISHES,
'CAUSE NOBODY'S PERFECT.
>> YOU SEEM TO HAVE
A REALLY GOOD AWARENESS
OF THE PRODUCTS.
>> I WENT REALLY NATURAL.
UM, A LITTLE BIT OF COLOR
UP HERE ON THE EYE,
AND THEN THE BLUSH
AND THE SIMPLE LIP.
>> THAT REALLY IS GONNA GO
A LONG WAY FOR YOU,
AND IT DEFINITELY WENT
A LONG WAY FOR YOU IN THIS ROOM.
YOU GUYS SHOULD GIVE YOURSELVES
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
YOU HAD NO TIME
TO DO AN AMAZING JOB,
AND I THINK
YOU ALL PULLED IT OFF.
BUT THE PERSON THAT WE CHOSE
AS THE WINNER
IS EUGENA.
>> YOU ACTUALLY
USED THE COLOR THE BEST.
>> (laughs)
NOW WHAT WE NEED YOU TO DO
IS CHOOSE TWO PEOPLE.
>> CARIDEE AND JAEDA.
>> HEY!
>> YOU'LL BE TAKING
A PHOTO SHOOT TOMORROW,
WHICH WILL BE FEATURED
ON THE COVERGIRL WEB SITE.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> 'BYE, GUYS.
>> 'BYE.
>> BYE-BYE. THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> YOU GUYS MET QUEEN LATIFAH?
>> YEAH.
>> I SHOOK HER HAND
AND EVERYTHING.
>> MONIQUE SEEMED PRETTY PISSED,
SO I THINK I'M GONNA AVOID HER
FOR, LIKE, THE REST OF THE DAY.
♪♪
>> MONIQUE, HOW LONG
ARE YOU GONNA BE ON THE PHONE?
>> I'M SO PISSED OFF.
DO YOU KNOW
THEY GOT TO MEET QUEEN LATIFAH?
>> TONIGHT I REALLY NEED
TO GET ON THE PHONE
WITH MY LANDLORD.
I NEED TO TALK TO HER
ABOUT POTENTIALLY GETTING
MY DEPOSIT BACK.
I'M GONNA LOSE $1,000.
>> YEAH, ME, TOO.
NO RESPONSE.
I GOT NOTHING.
>> THESE LITTLE RAGGEDY
NON-TOP-TEN-MODELS--
>> Sweetie--
>> AIN'T NEVER EVEN THOUGHT
ABOUT BEING A MODEL TILL THEY
WALKED INTO THE AUDITION,
AND ALL A SUDDEN THEY WANNA COME
IN HERE AND ACT LIKE
THEY THE STUFF. WHAT?
>> MONIQUE.
>> WE WERE TRYING
TO GET HER ATTENTION,
SO EVERYBODY WAS THINKING
OF FUNNY WAYS, YOU KNOW,
TO PISS HER OFF,
LIKE, JUST JOKING AROUND.
>> THERE'S ONE WAY TO DO IT.
>> NO, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
>> I'M JUST ENJOYING
THIS PHONE CALL. IT'S GREAT.
>> "I'M REALLY ENJOYING
MY PHONE CONVERSATION.""
WHAT IS THAT?
TWO YEAR OLDS DO THAT.
>> IT'S NOT OUR FAULT
YOU COULDN'T GET
IN THE DAMN ELEVATOR.
DON'T TAKE IT OUT ON US.
>> When they mess
with a child of God,
they got trouble on they hands.
You tell 'em, "I am
a 'Princess of the Throne.'"
>> SHE'S A DRAMA QUEEN.
SHE'S JUST
A STUPID LITTLE BITCH.
HELLO?
GET UP.
>> DO NOT HANG UP MY PHONE!
>> HANG UP!
>> DO NOT HANG UP MY PHONE.
>> OH, MY... STUPID.
>> DO NOT TOUCH THE...
YOU DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT
TO COME IN HERE
AND HANG UP ON... CONVERSATION.
>> ...AN HOUR.
IT'S AN HOUR ENOUGH.
>> YOU NEED TO GO TALK
TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
DON'T YOU EVER COME AND TOUCH...
>> DON'T... TOUCH ME.
>> YOU NEED TO QUIT TOUCHING ME.
>> BROO!
THERE'S... PEOPLE THAT
GOTTA PAY FOR... APARTMENT.
>> THAT'S OKAY,
AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HELL
I'M ON THE PHONE TALKING ABOUT,
OKAY?
SO YOU GET OUT OF MY FACE
AND GO IN THERE.
I'M NOT HERE TO MAKE FRIENDS
WITH YOU GUYS.
I COULD CARE LESS.
>> LEARN TO RESPECT
OTHER PEOPLE.
>> HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS IS MY TIME.
I'M NOT GETTING OFF THE PHONE.
>> IF YOU'D LIKE
TO MAKE A CALL,
PLEASE HANG UP AND TRY AGAIN.
(busy signal)
>> YOU GUYS CAN ALL
KISS MY GRITS AS FAR AS I CARE.
OH, I'M SORRY I SPENT SO LONG
ON THE PHONE!
SORRY!
YOU GUYS CAN USE THE PHONE.
OH, MY GOD!
IS IT TYRA MAIL?
OH! LET ME RUN.
>> EVERYONE NEEDS TO STOP
RESPONDING TO HER.
SERIOUSLY.
>> EVENTUALLY,
SHE WILL BE SO FED UP
WITH BEING THE MOST HATED GIRL
IN THIS HOUSE,
THAT IT'LL BE MISERABLE
FOR HER TO BE HERE.
>> THEY KEEP DISRESPECTING ME,
THEN I MIGHT, YOU KNOW,
BUST OUT OTHER SCENE
LIKE THAT AGAIN, YOU KNOW?
>> GUYS, IT'S TYRA MAIL!
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "IT'S TIME TO WIG OUT,
PUMP UP THE VOLUME..."
>> YAY.
>> "AND GET AMPED.
CAN YOU HANDLE IT, BABY?"
>> OH, YEAH.
>> I CAN HANDLE IT!
>> ALL RIGHT!
>> GOOD MORNING, AMERICA.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING!
>> NOW LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YESTERDAY.
EUGENA, YOU MET WITH
MISS QUEEN LATIFAH,
AND YOU MOST EMBODIED
THE NEW YOUNG QUEEN LOOK, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> WHO ARE YOUR TWO FRIENDS?
>> JAEDA AND CARI.
>> SO THE THREE OF YOU GIRLS
GET TO DO A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND WE'RE GONNA
SHOOT YOU GIRLS FIRST.
THIS IS REALLY
YOUR FIRST TASTE
OF COVERGIRL.
MAKE IT WORK FOR YOU.
>> I THINK THE GIRLS MIGHT BE
A LITTLE BIT JEALOUS, BUT...
WHAT CAN YOU DO?
I REALLY DON'T CARE.
>> OKAY. GOOD.
>> OKAY, YOU THREE,
GO AHEAD AND GET CHANGED
AND MEET US BACK OUT FRONT.
WE HAVE NEVER
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE THIS MUCH FUN
ON A PHOTO SHOOT.
WE HAVE FLOWN IN
THREE VERY SPECIAL PEOPLE
TO DO SOME OF THE MOST CRAZY,
OUTRAGEOUS
HAIR.
HAIR SHOWS LIKE "HAIR WARS"
FEATURE GIANT, CRAZY WIGS
THAT OFTEN HAVE MOVING PARTS.
THESE STREET STYLES
HAVE CROSSED OVER
TO THE RUNWAYS,
AND TODAY YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO ROCK THIS STYLE.
>> OH! WHOO!
>> THE THEME OF TODAY IS,
"DOES THE HAIR WEAR YOU,
OR DO YOU WEAR THE HAIR?"
LET ME INTRODUCE YOU
TO YOUR TEAM.
>> BAM!
>> (laughter)
>> HI!
>> I'M MR. LITTLE.
>> HEY, MR. LITTLE!
>> HEY.
>> I'M LISA B.
>> HEY!
>> AND I'M WEAVIN' STEVEN.
>> (laughter)
>> YOU GUYS READY
TO GET WORKING?
>> YEAH!
>> I'M RED?
>> YEAH, YOU'RE RED.
>> YOU'VE GOT, LIKE,
A SUITCASE FULL OF HAIR.
>> YOU CAN'T DO THIS
WITH YOUR EVERYDAY CLIENT.
THEY ALL SAY, "DON'T GIVE ME
ONE OF THOSE CRAZY HAIRDOS!"
(laughs)
>> (laughs)
>> HE CUT, LIKE,
LAYERS IN THE FRONT,
THEN HE GAVE ME A LITTLE SWOOP,
AND THEN I HAVE, LIKE,
THE TROPHY ON MY HEAD
'CAUSE I'M A WINNER.
>> YOU COME THROUGH
ALL OF THAT HAIR AND MAKEUP.
CAN YOU SELL ME YOU,
AND NOT THIS?
>> DO I HAVE TO HAVE THE FAN ON?
>> IT DOES A NICE LITTLE GLISTEN
ON YOUR EYES.
JUST FOR A LITTLE HINT
IN BEAUTY.
MAKES THEM
NOT QUITE SO DRY-LOOKING.
>> RIGHT.
>> A LOT OF THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE WATCHING ME,
AND I WAS LIKE, "YOU KNOW WHAT,
BOOP ALL YOU GUYS."
YOU KNOW, "LOOK AT ME."
AND I WAS JUST
ENJOYING MY SHOOT.
>> YOU KNOW, MONIQUE,
I'M GONNA BE HONEST WITH YOU--
THIS IS PRETTY GOOD.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> LOOK AT YOU, LOOK AT YOU.
>> IT'S ALL RIGHT.
>> ANCHAL, I NEED A SPARK.
I LOVE YOUR BODY LANGUAGE.
EVERYTHING IS WORKING
IN YOUR FAVOR RIGHT NOW.
>> AAH!
>> HEY, BROOKE,
WE NEED SOMETHING
CRAZY OR ZANY.
>> AAH!
AAH!
>> I LIKE THAT YOU STEPPED OUT
OF YOURSELF...
>> YEAH.
>> TO DO SOMETHING
THAT WASN'T SAFE.
>> FIND THE ANGLES ABOUT THIS.
>> CAN I USE MY HANDS?
I WANTED TO DO IT LIKE THIS.
>> YEAH, SURE.
>> AMANDA,
YOU'VE GOT GREAT FEATURES.
YOU SHOULD USE THEM
TO YOUR ADVANTAGE.
>> REALLY WORK THAT NECK FOR ME.
THERE YOU GO.
>> IT'S A BIRDHAWK.
IT'S NOT A MOHAWK,
IT'S A BIRDHAWK.
>> I LOOKED ACTUALLY
REALLY COOL,
BUT IT WAS REALLY FUNNY
AT THE SAME TIME.
I SERIOUSLY RESEMBLED
TOUCAN SAM.
>> REALLY GOOD, MICHELLE.
ACTIVATE THE SPINNERS.
DROP THE SHOULDER DOWN.
IT MAKES YOU LOOK
LONGER AND LEANER.
MEGAN, WHAT ARE YOU...
THINKING?
>> I'M TRYING TO THINK
OF EMOTIONS, LIKE...
>> YOU'RE TRYING TO THINK
OF EMOTIONS,
OR YOU HAVE AN EMOTION?
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
AT BREAKFAST THE OTHER DAY--
BEING IN A PLACE
WHERE WE'RE VULNERABLE.
>> I DIDN'T REALIZE
HOW HARD IT WAS
TO SHOW EMOTION IN YOUR FACE,
BUT YOUR REALLY DO
HAVE TO PUT YOURSELF
BACK TO A CERTAIN TIME
TO WHERE YOU FELT A CERTAIN WAY.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MEGG
GIVE ME SOMETHING
THAT'S A LITTLE MORE QUIRKY.
>> (shouts)
>> WELL, THAT'S KIND OF COOL.
>> BEAUTIFUL, HONEY.
>> ADORABLE.
ALL RIGHT, A.J.!
DROP THE HAND DOWN.
THE HAND CAN RUIN THE SHOT.
>> YOUR KNEES AND EVERYTHING.
THIS IS IN FRONT.
TAKE YOU BACK ONE UP.
EUGENA--
SHE HAD THE ATTITUDE OF,
"I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT I'M DOING,"
AND SHE KNEW NOTHING.
>> CARIDEE,
GIVE ME SOME FIRE, GIRL.
>> BEAUTIFUL, DOLL.
>> YOUR SHOTS ARE SO POWERFUL.
UGH, I'M REALLY HAPPY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WORK IT, GIRL. WORK IT!
SHOW ME WHAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH.
>> LET'S GO.
OOH, I LIKE THIS ONE.
LOOK AT THIS!
>> SHE'S MAKING UP
FOR LAST WEEK.
>> (growls)
>> MELROSE, YOU DID SO GOOD!
>> YAY!
>> LIKE, I DON'T KNOW--
WHERE DID THAT COME FROM?
>> THAT'S WHAT I'VE REALLY GOT.
>> LIKE A KID AT CHRISTMAS.
>> I JUST REALLY TRIED TO FOCUS
ON WHAT THE PHOTOGRAPHER
WAS DOING,
AND I ENDED UP
GETTING, LIKE, ANGRY,
AND I THINK I SHOWED THAT
IN MY PICTURES.
>> ALL I'VE GOT
FOR ABOUT 40 FRAMES
IS "WOMAN IN THE GREEN WIG."
OH, SHE DIDN'T LISTEN TO ME
AT ALL.
YOU WANNA GO HOME?
>> NO.
>> GIVE ME SOMETHING ELSE.
YOU GOT FOUR SHOTS TO DO IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO NOW.
>> THAT'S IT.
I DIDN'T SEE A CHANGE
IN THOSE FOUR FRAMES AT ALL.
>> OH, MY GOD.
♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "TOMORROW,
YOU'LL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 11 WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> AMANDA WAS READING
THE TYRA MAIL,
AND BEFORE I KNEW IT,
MELROSE JUST WENT CRAZY.
>> AAH!
AAH!
UGH, I'M GONNA VOMIT!
MONIQUE PUTS HER HAND
UP HER WET TOWEL,
AND, LIKE, GOES LIKE THAT
ONTO MY FACE.
>> (laughing)
>> LOOK AT--OH, MY GOD!
>> NOT MY FACE!
IT SMELLS LIKE AN EGG.
NO, LIKE,
17-YEAR-OLD SPOILED PUMPKIN.
>> (speaking indistinctly)
>> ♪ DO, DO, DO, DO ♪
>> NONE OF US WANT TO SEE
ANYBODY GO HOME EXCEPT MONIQUE,
BECAUSE SHE'S CRAZY,
AND WE'RE, LIKE,
CAN'T LIVE WITH HER.
LIKE, SHE'S IMPOSSIBLE
TO LIVE WITH.
>> (laughing)
♪♪
>> I DON'T RECOGNIZE
ANY OF YOU.
YOU ALL LOOK AMAZING.
YOU KNOW ABOUT
OUR FABULOUS PRIZES.
FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT,
WHICH IS ONE
OF THE TOP MODEL AGENCIES
IN THE WORLD...
A COVER OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE
AND A 6-PAGE
FASHION EDITORIAL SPREAD
IN "SEVENTEEN" AS WELL.
AND WE ALL KNOW ABOUT
THAT COVERGIRL CONTRACT
WORTH $100,000.
AND, OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED, FABULOUS
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
RUNWAY DIVA
TEACHER EXTRAORDINAIRE...
TWIGGY--FASHION ICON.
>> HELLO.
>> AND MISS TRACY BAYNE,
THE PHOTOGRAPHER
THAT SHOT YOU ALL THIS WEEK.
AND YOU HAVE BEEN AROUND
"TOP MODEL" FOR A WHILE NOW.
>> MM-HMM.
>> THE FIRST PHOTO SHOOT YOU DID
WAS THE HOROSCOPE PHOTO SHOOT--
WHICH WAS ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS--
AND YOU DID
THE GIRLS FALLING
AS PRINCESSES.
NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE WILL DISCUSS
WHICH ONE OF YOU LOVELY GIRLS
IS GOING HOME THIS WEEK.
SO MELROSE IS FIRST.
>> HELLO.
>> I LOVE YOU BLONDE.
>> YEAH.
>> VERY PRETTY.
>> I LOVE IT!
>> I NEVER KNEW
HOW BIG YOUR LIPS WERE.
>> THE MAKEOVER, IT SORT OF
JUST OPENS YOU UP.
YOU LOOK FRESH, YOUNG.
>> SO, MELROSE,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH SOME VERY WACKY HAIR
WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT DO THE "HAIR WARS"
IN THE HOOD, GIRL.
AS A MODEL,
YOU HAVE TO BREAK THROUGH
AND SHINE,
EVEN IF THERE ARE
SO MANY OTHER CRAZY THINGS
GOING ON.
SO LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
>> WOW.
>> I LOVE THE BODY MOVEMENT
IN THIS PHOTO.
IT'S--IT'S GENIUS.
>> THAT'S A UGLY, WEIRD,
STRANGE POSE THAT YOU'RE DOING,
BUT YOU'RE LIKE,
"OKAY, I'M GOING FOR IT."
ALL RIGHT, MELROSE. THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS ANCHAL.
(gasps)
>> GONE IS RAPUNZEL,
AND INSTEAD WE HAVE
A MODERN YOUNG LADY.
>> HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
I MEAN, THAT COULD
BE OUT OF "VOGUE," THAT SHOT.
YOU LOOK AMAZING.
>> IS THAT A WINDMILL
IN YOUR HAIR,
OR IS THAT ACTUALLY MOVING?
>> (laughing)
>> IT'S MOVING.
>> EVERY SINGLE GIRL'S HAIR
WAS MOVING.
>> BUT ONE THING--
YOU HAVE SUCH TINY FEATURES.
YOU NEED TO OVEREXAGGERATE THEM.
>> 'CAUSE THAT WAS JUST ONE SHOT
IN YOUR FILM.
I WANTED TO SEE, LIKE,
TEN OF THOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UP NEXT IS JAEDA.
WOW, LOOK AT YOU.
>> (chuckles)
>> I DON'T FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE OWNING IT.
I FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE SCARED OF THAT HAIR.
>> I'M STILL A LITTLE AWKWARD,
BUT IT'S GETTING BETTER.
>> I DON'T WANNA SEE THAT.
I DON'T WANNA FEEL THAT,
'CAUSE I'M, LIKE, "I GAVE HER
SOMETHING SO DRAMATIC,
SHE CAN'T HANDLE IT.
MAYBE SHE SHOULD JUST GO HOME
AND JUST COUNT THE DAYS
UNTIL HER HAIR GROWS BACK."
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOU'VE GOTTA MAKE IT LOOK
A LITTLE BIT MORE RELAXED.
IT'S ALMOST
AN AGGRESSIVE PICTURE.
>> YOU COME HERE,
AND THERE'S GIRLS
THAT ARE JUST AS PRETTY--
IF NOT PRETTIER--THAN YOU ARE.
YOU'RE NO LONGER
THE PRETTIEST GIRL
IN THE SCHOOL, AND I FEEL LIKE
IT'S GETTING TO YOU.
>> I JUST HAVE
TO GET USED TO IT.
>> ALL RIGHT, JAEDA. THANK YOU.
UP NEXT, MEGG.
LOOK AT YOU, MEGG.
I LOVE YOUR HAIR!
>> I WAS THINKING, "WHO'S THAT?
THAT'S SOMEBODY NEW."
YOU LOOK SO DIFFERENT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SO, MEGG,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
>> YOU HAVE TO WORK WITH
THAT UNDERBITE,
BECAUSE IN THIS PICTURE
IT'S COMING THROUGH
A LITTLE BIT.
>> THE MINUTE YOU RELAXED,
YOU JUST TURNED INTO, LIKE,
A NORMAL GIRL, SO YOU GOTTA...
PULL THAT MODEL OUT.
NEXT IS CARIDEE.
SO YOU'RE A LITTLE WET TODAY.
IS THAT WET?
>> REMEMBER WHAT WE SAID
ABOUT THE CLEAN PALETTE,
THE TYING IT BACK,
SHOWING US YOUR FEATURES?
>> YEAH.
>> THIS ISN'T IT.
>> CARIDEE,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
>> YOU MANAGED TO DO THAT SHOT
WITHOUT LOSING YOUR NECK,
WHICH IS VERY, VERY GOOD.
>> YOU LOOK A LITTLE MANNISH
IN THIS PICTURE.
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
YOU'VE GOT THAT STRONG JAWBONE,
WHICH CAN MAKE YOU LOOK
A LITTLE DRAG.
>> DRAG ON, GIRL. DRAG ON.
>> (laughs)
>> UP NEXT IS EUGENA.
SO LET'S SEE THIS HAIR, EUGENA.
PULL IT FORWARD.
>> OKAY.
>> YOU LOOK GORGEOUS.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> HMM.
>> YOU JUST LOOK TOO MASCULINE
IN THAT PHOTOGRAPH FOR ME.
AND I LIKE ANDROGYNOUS,
BUT THAT LOOKS...
MANLY.
>> YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING,
"WHY WAS THAT PICTURE CHOSEN?"
IT WAS THE ONLY PICTURE
THAT YOU GAVE ANYTHING.
IT WAS LIKE YOU WERE ASLEEP WITH
YOUR EYES OPEN ON THIS SHOOT.
>> I GAVE YOU SO MUCH DIRECTION,
BUT THE LOOK IN YOUR FACE IS,
"OH, I ALREADY KNOW THAT."
>> YOU EVEN VERBALLY SAID THAT
YOU THINK THAT YOU'RE BETTER
THAN THE OTHER GIRLS
IN PAST SEASONS OF "TOP MODEL."
YOU NEED TO REWIND...
>> I'LL REWIND.
>> AND EAT SOME HUMBLE PIE.
BUT THE ONE GOOD THING
IS YOU WON THE CHALLENGE
THIS WEEK.
QUEEN LATIFAH VOTED HER
AS THE BEST PUT-TOGETHER GIRL.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, EUGENA.
MICHELLE.
>> IT LOOKS NOW,
IT LOOKS CONTEMPORARY,
AND I THINK YOU REALLY
NAILED IT.
>> I WAS IMPRESSED
GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
MISS MICHELLE.
THAT LITTLE KISS
OF THE SHOULDER?
THAT WAS HOT.
AGAIN,
LOTS OF SHOTS TO CHOOSE FROM.
THAT'S A GOOD PROBLEM TO HAVE.
ALL RIGHT, MICHELLE. THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS YOUR SISTER,
AMANDA.
ANOTHER GINGER GIRL.
THAT LOOKS BEAUTIFUL ON YOU.
CAN WE SEE IT
BEHIND YOUR EARS, THOUGH?
ACTUALLY, YOUR EARS ARE BIG,
BUT THAT'S PRETTY.
THAT'S, LIKE--MAKES YOU, YOU,
AND, LIKE, ORIGINAL,
AND I LOVE THE BIG EARS.
SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> WOW.
>> OOH!
>> OOH.
>> YOU CAME UP AND SAID,
"YOU KNOW WHAT,
I'VE BEEN LOOKING IN THE MIRROR
AND THIS IS THE SIDE
THAT IT LOOKS BEST AT."
AND YOU FOUND IT.
>> ALL RIGHT,
UP NEXT IS BROOKE.
WHOA.
>> THE LUSCIOUS BRUNETTE.
>> THAT LOOKS BEAUTIFUL ON YOU.
YOUR EYES, LIKE, POP.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO COME THROUGH
SOME VERY BIG PATRIOTIC HAIR.
>> YES, MA'AM.
>> WELL, LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
>> CHILD,
MY COUNTRY 'TIS OF THEE!
>> THAT IS--
IT'S A GREAT SHOT OF YOU.
WHEN I LOOK AT YOU IN PERSON,
I WORRY THAT
PERHAPS YOU'RE TOO CUTESY.
BUT THE FACT THAT
YOU CAN DELIVER A SHOT LIKE THIS
GIVES ME FAITH.
>> BROOKE, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> MEGAN.
LET'S SEE IF YOU WERE ABLE
TO POP OUT
FROM ALL THAT CRAZINESS.
>> LOOKING AT THAT PHOTOGRAPH,
IT-IT LOOKS LIKE SOMETHING FROM
A FUNNY '50s LADIES MAGAZINE.
>> I'M NOT HAPPY.
I NEED MORE NECK.
>> THIS IS NOT A GREAT PICTURE.
IN FACT, THIS IS PROBABLY
THE WEAKEST SHOT WE'VE SEEN
OUT OF THE BUNCH.
>> SHE DOESN'T EVEN HAVE
A LOT OF HAIR,
FROM WHAT I CAN SEE.
>> NO.
>> MM-HMM.
>> YOU GOT LOST, AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS PHOTO SHOOT WAS ABOUT--
IS ABOUT NOT GETTING LOST
WITH ALL OF THAT,
'CAUSE THERE'S A LOT GOING ON.
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS A.J.
LOOK AT YOU!
OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> IT TAKES AWAY THAT
KIND OF GOTHY THING AS WELL.
>> YEAH. WOW.
>> MMM.
>> MMM, VERY PECULIAR.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL THAT
WHEN A PHOTOGRAPHER IS LOW,
THEY'RE GETTING AMAZING ANGLES.
THAT'S WHY YOUR BODY
AND EVERYTHING LOOKS GREAT,
'CAUSE HER CAMERA'S
LOWER THAN YOU ARE--
IT'S DOWN HERE.
BUT YOUR NOSE GOT A LITTLE BIG.
ALL RIGHT, A.J.
>> VERY GOOD.
>> THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT,
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
IS MONIQUE.
>> I LOVE THE PICTURE
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH
A GREAT GRAPHIC SHOT,
BUT I DON'T ACTUALLY
LIKE YOU IN IT.
>> THE FACE IS LIKE
A MOBILE PHONE
WITHOUT A SIGNAL--
BLANK.
>> MR. JAY SAID THAT
YOU HAD A HUGE IMPROVEMENT
FROM YOUR FIRST SHOOT.
THE FIRST SHOOT WAS SO BAD,
YOU HAD NOWHERE TO GO BUT UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT, WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
♪♪
>> ALL RIGHT,
SO WHO'S GOING HOME?
WE GOTTA DECIDE RIGHT NOW.
>> (grunts)
>> START WITH MICHELLE.
>> I THINK MICHELLE
IS ONE OF THE STRONG ONES.
>> HER LEANING TO HER LEFT
LIKE THAT LOOKS LIKE
SHE REALLY KNOWS
WHAT SHE'S DOING.
AMANDA.
>> AMANDA--
LOVE, LOVE, LOVE, LOVE.
>> FOR ME, MICHELLE IS STRONGER,
BUT I THINK
THEY'RE VERY UNIQUE--
THE PAIR OF THEM, ACTUALLY.
>> EUGENA.
>> WITH THIS SORT
OF AMATEUR MODELING,
SHE'S NEVER GONNA MAKE IT.
>> SHE DIDN'T WANT
ONE WORD OF ADVICE.
>> I THINK THAT
SHE DOES HAVE POTENTIAL.
BROOKE.
>> I THINK BROOKE
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A MODEL.
SHE LOOKS LIKE
A LITTLE CUTE CHEERLEADER.
RAH, RAH, RAH, SIS BOOM BAH.
>> MEGG.
>> SHE'S GOT TERRIBLE POSTURE.
>> I FEEL LIKE MEGG
IS REALLY TRYING AND STRUGGLING.
A.J.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, A.J. HAS
SO MANY OF THOSE THINGS
THAT THE FASHION PEOPLE LOVE--
THE AWKWARDNESS,
THE SORT OF BIRDLIKE QUALITIES,
THE GREAT SKIN.
>> I JUST WISH SHE WANTS THIS
AS MUCH AS I WANT HER
TO WANT IT.
>> JAEDA.
SHE CANNOT HAVE ANYTHING
TO DISTRACT HER,
BECAUSE SHE JUST GETS LOST.
>> JAEDA WAS PAINFUL.
>> SHE JUST LOOKS UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> MEGAN.
>> MEGAN HAS A LOOK
THAT I'VE SEEN BEFORE...
(singsongy) BORING!
>> SHE'S GOT A GREAT BODY,
SHE'S GOT THAT GREAT
BONE STRUCTURE,
BUT SHE HAS NOT BROUGHT IT
TO THIS PICTURE.
>> THIS IS MY LEAST FAVORITE
PHOTOGRAPH.
>> ANCHAL.
>> I LOVE THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
SHE'S CONNECTED WITH THE CAMERA.
>> SHE REALLY IS SERVING SOME
REALLY STRONG, NICE TINA TURNER.
MELROSE.
>> I LIKE HER.
THE MAKEOVER DID WELL.
I LOVE HER BODY LANGUAGE.
>> I THINK MELROSE
HAS DONE A COMPLETE 180.
SHE WAS UP AND SHE WAS TOGETHER.
>> MONIQUE.
>> WHEN I FIRST SAW HER,
I THOUGHT,
"WHAT A BEAUTIFUL BLACK GIRL."
BUT HER PICTURES
AREN'T DOING IT FOR ME.
>> MONIQUE IS SO PRETTY.
SHE REALLY HAS THAT
SORT OF "CHARLIE'S ANGELS" LOOK
ABOUT HER,
WITH THAT CURLY HAIR
COMING DOWN.
FOR MONIQUE TO DELIVER THIS
AS A PICTURE
JUST SCREAMS,
"I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M DOING."
>> CARIDEE.
>> SHE LOOKS QUITE DRAG,
AND I THINK THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT SHE HAS TO DEAL WITH.
>> I LOVE HER LOOKING LIKE
A DRAG QUEEN
IN THIS PICTURE, THOUGH.
>> I'VE NOTICED.
>> IT'S A GOOD THING.
>> (laughs)
>> REACH YOUR DECISION.
LET'S GO.
>> 12 YOUNG GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE 11 PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE 11 OF YOU THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
MELROSE.
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> LAST WEEK,
YOUR PICTURE WAS DREADFUL.
BUT THIS PICTURE
LOOKS LIKE A MODEL
THAT WOULD ONLY WAKE UP
FOR $10,000 A DAY.
CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ANCHAL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AMANDA.
MICHELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> A.J.
CARIDEE.
>> OOH, GOD.
>> BROOKE.
EUGENA.
CONGRATULATIONS, EUGENA.
>> MEGG.
CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I WILL CALL...
MONIQUE.
>> CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL JAEDA AND MEGAN
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL CALL ONLY ONE NAME,
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO YOUR HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO.
IT'S INTERESTING,
YOU BOTH STANDING BEFORE ME,
BECAUSE MEGAN AND JAEDA,
YOU GUYS HAVE SHORT HAIRCUTS.
AND TO THE EYE,
YOU BOTH LOOK SO STRONG.
BUT YOU TWO FAILED THE CHALLENGE
OF THE PHOTO SHOOT THIS WEEK
MISERABLY.
WE LOST BOTH OF YOU
BEHIND ALL THAT HAIR
IN THE PHOTO SHOOT.
BUT MAYBE ONE OF YOU
CAN BE FOUND.
>> JAEDA.
>> LOOK AT THAT.
WHO IS THAT?
WHAT IS THAT?
YOU NEED TO GO HOME
AND THROW A MOP
OVER YOUR HEAD...
>> (chuckles)
>> AND SEE IF YOU CAN MODEL
THROUGH THAT.
THAT IS YOUR CHALLENGE.
CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU, MEGAN.
>> (whispers) OKAY.
BYE, GUYS.
IT'S SAD, YOU KNOW,
SAYING GOOD-BYE.
I AM SURPRISED THAT, LIKE,
I WENT THIS EARLY
BECAUSE I THOUGHT I WAS GONNA
LAST LONGER THAN THAT.
BUT IN MODELING,
YOU'RE NOT GIVEN
VERY MANY OPPORTUNITIES.
I WISH I WAS
MORE MYSELF UP THERE
IN FRONT OF THE JUDGES,
AND, YOU KNOW,
MAYBE I COULD'VE
SHOWN A LITTLE MORE CHARACTER.
♪♪